Brazil's agricultural industry accounts
for one third of its GDP the country is
the world's biggest exporter of meat and
farmers in the state of maturg on the
largest cattle herd in the country most
of them are staunch supporters of
President Jaye bolsonaro who is running
for a second term they say he protects
their interests
our right to produce and Thrive without
the risk of having our Farms invaded by
the landless and the indigenous people
he's allowed us have arms to defend our
private property bolsonaro chose a small
party to run his re-election bid when it
ran low on funds Farmers like kohaya
donated thousands to keep it going
small and medium-sized producers rarely
dig into their pockets to finance
politicians we don't trust them but
bolsonaro supports us and doesn't treat
us like environmental criminals many
like myself have kept a percentage of
our lands untouched as required by law
both molsonaro and leftist candidate
Luis Da Silva are looking to win support
of those who voted for other candidates
in the first round of the presidential
election
was the right of Center candidate who
came in third
she says she's also a strong advocate
for small farmers but now she supports
leftist candidate Louisiana
[Music]
during Lula's previous government the
agricultural industry boomed but he also
financed Family Farm production now
Brazil still feeds the world but 33
million Brazilians are going hungry
many plots that were once owned by big
landowners are now divided among small
farmers who produce food organically in
this patch of land there are 30
different kinds of vegetables and fruits
like for example we have here a papaya
tree over there a banana tree there's
coffee there's peanuts lettuce garlic
all of these are produced without the
use of pesticides
183 families make a living in these
seven hectares they distribute their
produce to poor families and local
indigenous tribes or reclaiming their
lands but these families don't have the
same economic or political clout as
Brazil's powerful Farm Lobby
which is why bolsonaro counts on them to
keep him in power Monica yanakaval
Jazeera matogorosu Brazil